[Music]
we did the original idea for unbreakable
come from and propelled you to write it
I guess during post-production for The
Sixth Sense
yeah when I was editing success I was
writing unbreakable originally it was a
plane crash and a guy survives and then
some and is told someone says I think
you might be a real-life superhero but
then I put it into a train because I
love trains and I felt was more comic
book II for me and and then it and then
it felt more reasonable that he would
survive without a scratch and so could
be dismissed as luck
but then Elijah's character you know
comes to him and says no I think you
might be a superhero so this idea of a
regular person who doesn't have anything
to do with superheroes and in a world
that that doesn't exist is told hey you
know these fake things and comic books I
think they're actually based on people
like you
there was no at that time really no
comic book movies that had ever come out
and it was a silly thing to make a movie
about it just felt very confusing I
think for the studio at that time and it
was seen as a fringe element of the
movie that this is about comic books oh
oh those are those weirdos that hang out
at those conventions you know again back
then there was there was jest comic-con
and it was very niche at that time you
know I know people weren't aware of it
and it you know was more cult-like kind
of stuff so they said let's not make
this a cult subject movie so let's sell
it more as a general thriller we're
never gonna mention comic Boyd's comic
books superheros any of that so then
that meant you couldn't even do the main
plot of the movie because that's the
plot of the movie hey I think you're a
real-life superhero that couldn't be
said and then in the ads so it was
really weird and ironic time that the
thing that dominates the film industry
now it was the one thing they were
running from they thought that was the
least commercial element of the film so
really obviously times have changed a
great deal
you wrote the role of David for Bruce
correct why was he the perfect person
for this hero you know we just done
Sixth Sense and I guess he and I I was
feeling were were kind of a team and I
one of my favorite movies is Pulp
Fiction and I really wanted that flavor
that Sam and
gave in in Pulp Fiction for I'm
breakable obviously a totally different
story and all of that stuff about that
kind of cool edgy grounded quality that
they both had I thought you know his
quietness versus his pizzazz could be
really fun so it was really from from
from Quinton that I kind of grabbed that
that union it's always terrifying direct
for me but at that time I think I was 29
when I was doing unbreakable or it may
be even 28 when I wrote it think you
know it was still in early stages of my
career and those guys were icons and so
and I was being very aggressive about
the way we were making the movie long
takes three-minute takes two minute
takes four minutes so really aggressive
filmmaking and they just have to trust
me there's no clothes upstairs no this
does knows that and it's very it's very
play like and so it feels very illogical
when I'm saying hey we're gonna do this
shot it's gonna do like this and eight
people are gonna talk and if the eighth
person in a minute minute two and a half
makes a mistake we're gonna have to do
this shot over again a lot of people
would say we're not gonna do it that way
we're just not doing it I'm not gonna
nail it and then have that person masa
de but I believe in the theater of
cinema that way that that there there's
a reason that person won't mess up is
because you're all connected in this
ineffable way and they started to
believe in it but at first it was very
intimidating I mean I mean he had
certain ways he wanted us to do things
and he would tell us to do you know it's
like as an actor I can dream up through
the theater and theater is essentially a
dictatorship you know the director tells
you to do something you do it or they
ask you a question you have to have the
right answer to justify what you're
doing Knight went further than that it
was like I already know what you're
going to do and I want you to do it this
way so we were kind of like his puppets
in an interesting kind of way do you
remember a particular moment or scene
from the first film yeah I'm a network
that worked there were specific times he
would say you know okay try not to blink
do the whole team without blinking
really or he would say don't say the
line that way say it this way and I'm
one of those actors that hates being
given line readings but he was very
adamant about it even though later on
you know we did ADR he'd go back in that
land what he wanted to do it do it that
way which one made the cut mine and what
was it like working with birdseed
obviously worked with him before
bruton I've been around together for you
know quite a bit so going around around
in that so it was kind of easy for us to
kind of listen the night or look at
night and kind of look at each other and
go yeah well this kid finds out yeah you
know it slowly grew you know when the
movie opened I think there was a kind of
a disconnect because they were thinking
I was kind of a sequel to 6/6 sense
because me and Bruce and we sold it like
that sold it like it was a thriller only
and no no understanding of the comic
book world and so there was confusion
people were coming to see a scary movie
and that's not what they saw you know so
there was really a disconnect but
immediately as the DVD came out you
started to feel the change in their
perception of the movie and oh wait this
is about comic books and then again six
months later six months later six months
later it just kept growing and growing
until you know I would cross the street
then if you and I were hanging out
invariably someone would come up to us
and say I'm breakable I love it man when
are you making the sequel when you're
making the sequel and that would grow
and now even before split the first
thing I would say in the press junket is
I'm gonna answer your first question
already no I'm not making a sequel dumb
breakable okay next question and then we
would continue along so it became a big
thing you could feel it everywhere that
I went that this thing of unbreakable
was building and I do think over over
the years unbreakable is the one that
has grown the most
[Music]